Reckless is back on fnatic that's
something I thought I would never say
one of the most recognizable faces in
League of Legends has returned to the
team that made him and arguably he made
they've both been through a lot since
they split ways two years ago so why has
this happened is it actually a good idea
and together can they now achieve their
former glory
[Music]
thank you
all right there's a brand new year
coming up which might mean you're
thinking about refreshing your wardrobe
creating a new you for 2023 or let me
recommend to you our brand new merch
line we've got a whole bunch of new
items on there my personal favorite is
the touch grass hoodie which now also
comes in black and ivory if that sounds
like your sort of thing you can check it
out using the link in the description
below so for the better part of the
eight years between 2012 and 2020
Reckless was the face of Fanatics League
of Legends team through the many highs
and lows he was the Beating Heart for
the fans a Talisman for the orc the man
in black and orange Reckless and fanatic
seemed Inseparable together they
dominated early European League out of
the first six splits in the EU LCS
fnatic won five of them and apart from a
brief stint with elements in 2015
Reckless was there for every part of
that success in 2016 G2 not fanatic off
their Throne kickstarting the greatest
rivalry to region has ever seen and
although G2 came to be regarded as the
European number one fanatic and Reckless
still had their moments in the sun most
memorably when they made it all the way
to the Grand Final of world 2018.
[Applause]
now despite losing that series fnatic
had still made it to a World's final
something the Western teams have only
ever managed to do on two other
occasions Reckless stay with fnatic for
another two more years but the team
always seemed to fall short to G2
domestically and that's why it was
incredibly shocking when Reckless chose
to join the proverbial Enemy by signing
with G2 in November 2020 after eight
years with fnatic now at the time this
looked like G2 signing one of the
Region's greatest ever ad carries and
taking away a huge weapon from their
rivals in the process but Reckless and
G2 just didn't seem to click summer 2021
saw G2 finish in fourth place there were
spinach in three years and it meant the
team wouldn't attend worlds for only the
second time since the all qualified for
the EU LCS to a lot of people's surprise
Reckless was benched and according to
him this meant he was earning just six
percent of his normal wage as stipulated
in his contract with G2 so I understood
that part of the contract fully but I
was just naive to believe that they
wouldn't take me over take me over they
put me here which is why I really needed
to get the out of there because if
I stayed I would get no money and I
wouldn't be able to play I would just
sit and wait two years
so I had to get out he said he wanted to
move to another Lac team but the G2 made
his buyout price too high and only
lowered it when other teams had filled
up their rosters during the off season
so at this point according to Reckless
it sounded like he didn't really have
many options people speculated about
what his next move could be but not many
could have predicted what happened
Reckless made a move to the lfl team
Carmine Corps a French team that had
taken tier 2 European League by storm
after winning back-to-back European
Masters and the lfl spring Championship
it was a move that even saw Netflix
friends wishing him a warm welcome to
his new team the team had made a name
for themselves as having one of the most
passionate fan bases in Europe and one
thing was immediately clear on the
arrival of Reckless they loved
him
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Corp seem to click from day one they
both wanted the same thing to be in the
LEC and Reckless hit the ground running
with them by winning the European
Masters spring split Carmen Corps say to
LLC you are just another brick in the
wall and that wall is blue as Carmine
carp become the first ever treat
Champions all things considered it was
by no means a bad year for reckless
especially given his previous situation
but in October this year the orgs
co-owner announced that the team had not
been able to secure a spot in the LEC
for 2023. reckless had spoken before
about how happy and comfortable he was
with K Corp but at the same time it was
clear that he really wanted to be back
in the LEC and last month rumors began
to swell that Reckless and fanatic were
going to be reunited once again
especially when Reckless himself said he
was back now there was was no specific
mention of being back on fnatic there
but people read between the lines
confirmation finally came last week from
both Reckless and fanatic who released
an announcement video worthy of the fans
excitement at the return of their King
right now right now
it's good to be back
the new lineup will see Reckless paired
up with rocks as support alongside razor
in the jungle humanoid in mid and former
G2 teammate Wonder in the Top Lane and
the fans didn't have to wait too long at
all to see reckless in this new fnatic
lineup as the team took down koi last
weekend in a pre-lec show match in
Madrid oh here we go here we go baby
here we go Reckless
it's all quite surreal seeing Reckless
back in the black and orange of a
thematic Jersey but we have been here
before this is technically his fifth
stint with the org over the last 10
years something fanatic themselves were
quick to me more but will things be
different this time of course he spent a
year out of the LEC and two years apart
from fnatic it's not a certainty that
he'll just slot back in like nothing
happened at all but there's one person
who believes in Reckless it's Reckless
when he was asked on stream recently why
he left an attic in the first place he
admitted that he did have regrets but
seemed adamant that he could reach his
former Glory but there is nothing I can
do with that feeling like sitting here
and feeling sorry for myself not gonna
help anything so I'm not gonna do that
what I'm gonna do
is get myself out of this situation and
smash it okay like
I know not everyone believes in me but I
believe in myself and I have done it
before
I can do it again like
I will do it again it's
it's a matter of time it's not a matter
of if I can or not it's just a matter of
time it's been a while a couple of years
for reckless he left fanatic joined
their anime in G2 got benched fell out
with their owner left to play for a
wildly popular tier 2 French team and
now he's back where it all started he
has his regrets about what has happened
he's admitted that leaving fnatic was a
mistake but he returns to the team now
to rectify that with some hard-earned
lessons under his belt ready to continue
where he left off
[Music]
how was this concert last night it was
good it was good it was a real pain
trying to get there the train got
canceled so I ended up having to get
lifts from my dad I was very kind of him
this is this this can't be friendboard
by the way this is the most depressing
game whatever me me talking about public
transport what do you think of public
transport let me know in the comments
section big fan not a fan of it let me
know there you go that's them